we couldn't possibly do a makeover show
without the man who single-handedly gave
himself the most epic makeover in our
show's history
he not only lets his daughter
do his makeup but he also let me give it
a try and it turned out like this
look girls i can't believe it okay max
greenfield is a trendsetter a good sport
and he's also one of the stars of the
very popular and successful comedy
series the neighborhood take a look
calvin we're related
say what now
whoa
let let me see that
oh wow that is true
and if terry is dave's cousin and he's
also your cousin
that means you are hopefully adopted
bring it in cuz
[Applause]
please welcome back to our show our good
friend max greenfield
[Applause]
i see there's makeup here
you know we just thought since you were
such an amazing sport last time as well
as um just a beauty junkie maven you
know looking kind of guy we thought
double dip um i just wanted to let you
know my daughter was too milly
oh gosh well let's see if we could make
her proud today
drew i want to be taken seriously as an
actor and an author now and so i can't
you know looking like i did last time i
don't know that that's going to happen
so we really we have to make we have to
like
produce a sophisticated
look
all right well
i heard um that you actually
are about to be
the author of a children's book and i
couldn't be more excited max you got to
tell me about it well first let me apply
some lipstick please do
i feel confident about you putting this
on i wrote um a book called i don't want
to read this book it was for my kids um
during the lockdown
and it's written in the first person and
it's all the reasons why
you don't want to read a book and by the
end of the book the child or the adult
has read in a book
um i think you're going to really
captivate kids with this book because
you're getting them at their
level and you're being honest with them
you know sometimes we really pander to
kids and it's like they smell it you go
right ahead max and you apply that blush
i'm glad you told me what it was because
i just assumed that you take the brush
and you put it in here and
as they say you're a natural
thank you you're a little higher a
little higher apples of the cheeks there
oh oh yeah
yeah oh
yeah okay
max i am not messing with you right now
literally your eyes just popped i mean
this is what makeup does now i want to
talk to you about the neighborhood
because it just kicked off its fourth
season and
this show
is
i love
your show i love how much it resonates
with so many people i mean even your
kids who don't maybe want to read the
books they're watching the show
what do they think about the show kids
love it it's one of the few shows that
you can sit down with the whole family
and watch which is so nice and we're
back for fourth season everybody
you know it's one of those groups where
and you i'm sure you've been a part of
a show like this or a movie like this
where you go oh my god i just love
coming to work because the people are so
nice
well i think also you guys tackle really
important serious stuff on your show
which is why i want you to put on some
more makeup max
what do i do with this one um well with
that i think how do you feel about a
kitten eye max it's a kitten eye
i don't know what a cat eye is okay so
what you want to do is you want to open
your pen which you probably already have
and then you want to take the liner and
you want to go along the lash line and
then wing it out oh
max are you okay
oh no
it's okay
it's okay we're gonna we're gonna play
right through it
i'm doing a good now
[Laughter]
that's good let's get the other side
because we want it to be even and
balanced
um
oh my god all the women here are dying
oh the way you're holding it is
perfection
thank you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's it max that's it
max before we go i'm wondering if you
would attempt the scribble stick now if
you i would love to do me a favor i want
i want faye dunaway now baby i want
major contour in the cheeks just and
just do one line and one line
yep aha there you go yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes and yes
max you look
gorgeous
and you are the best sport
congratulations by the way on season
four
of the neighborhood which airs monday
thank you nights on cbs and max i will
see you so soon
thank you so much
[Music]
you